some projects a little bit about how we
made that decision then and where our
experiences so first of all what is go
so go is the new language developed at
Google when a couple years old I've even
seen one point one right now and it's so
this is sort of their like mission
statement or ethnicity our message but
it's surprisingly accurate this goes
gaining a lot of traction and it's sort
of every week you see more clothes I
have to me it's about people who wrote
like rewrote something to go and saw
massive speed up or ahead like a great
developer experience and we we sort of
seen some of the benefits as well so
let's dive into a little bit of balance
or what's going is before I talk about
how we ended up deciding to have to use
it your attention so go is a programming
language go link one quick tip if you
ever want to google anything and look up
anything about building you can start to
go because you're going to get the board
game so you have to go lame and and the
right things are gonna come up I have
learned the hard way so go and the main
programming language is a pretty
standard programming language few a sort
of question when people have
here about my is it statically typed
pile garbage collected it's not object
oriented but it has basically some
object-oriented capabilities and so this
is sort of the sample go program to
compute the tenth number the Fibonacci
sequence as you can see it as a package
system sort of like Java
the syntax for importing a little bit
different but the semantics are pretty
much exactly the same as the main
function is the entry point somewhere
that almost all programming languages
and this basically was pretty standard
there's one sort of point of indication
that it like goes everyone off a little
bit is that the variable names and
decorate and types Arbor first so this
is a function that takes a single
variable and of type int was like
reverse from how they usually would be
and it returns a single int but
otherwise pretty pretty standard stuff
but they're probably right so as I
mentioned the codes organizing the
packages makes a distinction between
pointers to values similar to see past
that value and it doesn't have objects
but it has struts which every standard
courtesy style struts and laughing
defined methods on structs but then I
think that could call it methods but the
idea is you to find a struct that it can
be called birthright a function can be
called by a struct so in this case if
you have any variable of type pointer to
a person you can call that variable dot
3 and it will call the greet function
passing in itself as the self variable
there and display of something so that's
someone either granted they also sort of
interesting things that's shown here is
dead there's no public or private
keywords and go instead well private it
in this case it's package private public
is really world readable and the way
that public and private are determined
is instead of keywords they're actually
determined apart whether or not the
first letter of the variable name is
capitalized or sorry the field name is
capitalized which is a little bit looks
a little strange at first but it is
actually ends up being very nice is much
less verbose and they sort of
is intuitive and a quick scan what
you're gonna be able to use outside the
package about what's being used
internally was more credit
okay so going to a couple other things
go ahead as first-class options it has a
really nice best facility that functions
can actually return multiple values so
you actually declare a function to
return any number of values so that
lease is sort of really common error
emily petticoat is the sort of that
universally use pattern for this is that
any function that can conceivably return
some sort of error returns an error
object as the last return value and is
the responsibility of the caller to
check that value to see whether or not
an error was produced so there's no
exceptions in go instead the idea is
basically catch the errors right when
they occur and ararat important you sort
of however you would use your error
handling
I'd also has go routines built-in which
are essentially about concurrent videos
they're essentially functions executing
concurrently at the same address space
with their own staff in place and to do
that you just call it go and then a
function call and they'll start that
function calling a separate governing
their conceptually very similar threads
PS development features go is really
nice dependency system the way that it's
built the language the executables
actually compile really fast in order
likely it was a pretty good program to
be compiled and I think seconds as
opposed to you might seem as long as it
is it's also pretty small language the
actual suspect online is like one pretty
long document I suppose to like a book
for Java so it's actually pretty easy to
just go through and sort of feel like
you hundred head wrapped around the
language
really surprised by a lot of features
that might crop up Nelson has a pretty
strong standard library space is like an
HTTP server built-in there's some the
next step process handling modules is a
what we're working with time and because
it Center this sort of a girl community
Ronco there's a lot of good plug-ins for
popular text editors okay so there's a
few other things that ship would go and
it worth mentioning because a lot of
them are not very nicely so go build is
just the pile but don't format is kind
of interesting because go basically
enforces a specific sky on all of your
code so if you run go format on your go
source files it'll actually format them
in a deterministic way using like
certain amounts of spaces and certain
items of like wine critics the spacing
between different parts so this is sort
of a way of ensuring that all the code
within a project is style the exact same
way or that like to have any sort of
disputes over what that way is going to
be those very opinionated Avella things
of them another your nice go test is
pretty interesting because it actually
go has like a very small unit testing
framework built into it that if you're
going to do like heavy unit testing we
use the go check package which basically
is
or to go and works in a lot of the same
ways but it's very easy to sort of cook
into that because the go test has its
own there go has its own testing built
into it one sort of weak point about go
that is definitely is the discussion
that is like currently in place about
how to how to improve this success on
the radar is the go path environment
variable so this is the environment
variable that you say it determines
where it go tool is going to look for
all of your library and for all of your
to stall libraries as well as all of
your source code and it's also we have
install if you go get things is gonna
install those into that it's the go that
the cells we created go down so this is
a little bit of things it's not quite
transparent and also it becomes hard to
separate out like code from different
projects because gonna be installing if
you want to make one project and another
project that you're working on on your
own those minions spelling and code for
that to the same place which you don't
really want as we look at the
dependencies in the same place which you
may not necessarily want
so one fix for that is it just like kind
of toggle between different go past me
or indifferent projects but right now
there isn't like a really convenient
it's I know that it's in the works
okay so just a little bit more about
billed as a kind of instrument to how we
use it for MongoDB is a driver for
MongoDB which is one actually not I
don't know as well notice as well known
as some of the other drivers but it's a
really really excellent mature driver
it's not one that was actually written
attention
I was written by a community member who
stopped a miner who's kind of a heavy
hitter in both the gold world and the
MongoDB world so he's really sort of a
good person to write this it's
definitely and yellow the website there
this is really nice tops
it's very standard it works exactly as
they expected
yeah a little bit of syntactic sugar
which is actually kind of nice like this
update ID method because updating or
finding a field base not only the
underscore ID is so common that you get
at a method that doesn't make you like
giving an entire piece on matter it will
just give a single a single item that
you expect to match the image link and
it's now stir affected rather than
passing another peridot date but
otherwise it's sort of very very
intuitive does a lot of the nice things
that you'd expect from a driver it pools
connections with only a tiny bit of
extra work from the norm as close to
discovery so if you give it a single URL
for every site it will discover
everything instead three preference off
has pretty vested in the piece on
implementation indigo is all started by
Gustavo it's it kind of looks here like
the sub package of M do but it's mango
but it's not actually you can use it um
but it's mainly used for interfacing
with MongoDB and for use with the actual
go driver for MongoDB and I'll select in
there which was actually orthography
with something very nice that the driver
did is that and it's a sort of about
your reason to use it to look at it is
that it has certain Leonia built into it
so go allows you so part of go is that
you can define it arbitrary string tags
for struct feels so you can say and this
is mainly
to be used for as Marshall it from my
other data formats into a struct we
didn't go even to find the tag that
might even namespace to Texas like this
is a struck the definition of a struct
it has three fields but has an idea to
create time the display name and that
each of those fields has a tag
associated with it so the tagging is
centers for a ZT d underscore name so
then when when you make a call so this
is fantastic collection that I can find
one and unfortunately in into a task
into a variable type of task or type
reference to attack plane when you do
that you don't need to sort of have any
middleware that's gonna look at the
return value from the database am i
clear into your own struck instead mango
actually knows that okay I'm gonna take
the document back from the database I'm
gonna looking under square ie feel an
article back I'm going to go back into
the release ID field and destruct and
take the CPP local Markland
create time etc and it also works the
other way so you don't need to worry
about like if you want to insert
something or update something young to
worry about populating
let's try to get off you can just say
insert and then the name it was struck
from it has the right tags so this is
really nice to kind of get this for free
when you use mom girl there they go
and you don't need to say anything else
I'm talk but it makes you very busy okay
so now that I've got a really about go
sort of how it interfaces with MongoDB
I'm going to go a little bit for the
projects that we're actually using tor
for how we decided to be done the first
one which I'm going to go to listen 90
loads more detail about after this kind
of section at the top is our new exactly
service that we recently released as
basically as hosted backups for MongoDB
we posted install a single agent on your
machine that agent close your data and
sends it to us and we back it up and we
can do it like a plain country stores we
take certain snapshots of it so if you
wanna restore it or serving a snapshot
just send the data over to you and of
course it supports churning clusters so
a brief overview of how it works because
it's relevant to sort of get you know
why we decided to use go for it is the
single agent for those of you who use
MMS it's very similar view that best
monitor mention it's sort of very
similar to how that works is it sits on
your machine
it sits on my customers machine next to
them on movie sinks all the data from it
and it starts tailing the alcohol so it
acts a lot like a secondary but it's
very lightweight process because instead
of sorry instead of actually storing the
data in any way it actually
that to us would restore so we are back
in storage as the actual outlawed
operations and if you do coke a that
like storage of your data and I'm going
to go into this one a little more in
center analog is sorry so when you have
a replica set make of like multiple
notes in a set an aqua is basically it's
just a log that the met all three of
them team of every operation that's
applied to of the database and then the
primary keep that log such as the
basically a circularbuffer of operations
that have been made rights updates
deletes and the center is where the
secondaries things sync with that is
they basically read off keep peeling off
the end of the primaries version and a
client goes to his own data so we just
do something very simple
okay so the backup agent so quite that
sits on the customer machine as
originally written in Java and it worked
it was we're pretty happy with it but we
sort of started to see some deployment
issues and sorry because it's the
process that there's on the customers
machine so Java can be a little bit of a
headache for deploying to a customer's
machine because you know they have a
different that they have a different
version of Java or a different like
distribution of Java or JVM than we had
originally intended things can kind of
we might have quirks that we don't
expect might have issues
how's it require lie other installed
libraries so they might not have to
install the actual actual jar for the
Java driver for MongoDB
so we then we realized that that was
probably going to be an issue and I want
to sort of make it ideally should be a
situation where they just go to our
website click the button download a
single program and run it without having
to worry about any sort of extra
deployment on that machine any sort of
extra configuration of their boxes or
it's away from it so go with really nice
for this first of all to compile but
it's also I didn't mention it's
statically linked which means that all
the libraries that a program needs are
actually compiled into the binary which
means so it doesn't link against
anything that it expects from either on
the target machine where it runs so that
means that go liners are very large but
they have zero dependencies you can just
drop one onto a machine and Ryan has all
the libraries that it needs package
within it so this is perfect for us
I also cross compiles very easily
basically when you compile a program all
you
SETI's go out west and the large flax
environment variables and then the
compiler for the correct distribution
and going see it just like a really nice
wrapper that someone wrote that compiles
it for any platforms that you might need
so yes so we at this point the back of
it you know is really go it's in
production and go and we've sort of had
great experience with it it's it was
picked up written very quickly with a
sort of a high learning curve our
developers are really easy time at it
really good working with it and she's
working exactly like they expected to so
now we know move on to our next project
that uses it whatever
so we sort of weren't happy with the
bill system that we were using and had a
couple of issues a lot of the continuous
integration systems that were on the
market
things like Jenkins or Travis they might
quite fit our needs so we decided we
were going to roll our own just like
corporate continuous integration system
which basically is a facility to just
constantly be building or compiling and
testing different versions of MongoDB so
that we can know that's passing on the
tests if it compiles correctly there
works on all the distributions we intend
as we build it we want it to be
paralyzed the bullet might be flexible
because we want to be able to use it to
sort of test the drivers to test have a
mask to test itself and we're just
didn't open sourcing at some point and
it's not much good terrible that starts
a product that can only be used to test
longer to be yeah so thanks to the way
it works in a nutshell is the single
master machine which stores all the
necessary configuration and Internet and
it has a backing database and pulls give
up there changes to the actual model ODB
source checks and twister changes pulls
down basically versions that need to be
compiled and tested and then
periodically compiles the agent process
that we wrote sends that process over to
a worker machine that process kicks off
the task as a step process of itself and
it reports back to the master it does
we've been we've been looking at
that's four for the moment it was sort
of quicker to get it off the ground with
a polar but we definitely take it for at
least investigating videos yes so this
is a bunch of work for Michigan's
running they already steps with the age
of the runs of them and if they report
back to the master machine whether the
test failed succeeded a stack of logs so
the issues that we saw with this we're
starting with the agent were very
similar to kind of resolve to back okay
today we are certain that we want to be
able to run on a lot of different
machines on a lot of different
distributions theoretically mean
anything that we need to support one
would be beyond we need to support this
program on because we need to be able to
build a test that would be to go to run
these steps and compile it through this
program a lot of those machines so we
wanted to be very free dependencies also
because a lot of these machines are
actually dynamically spun up the ec2
when we do when the master program
realizes that it needs them so we wanted
I mean it's kind of a nightmare to that
that you see a machine that you're
automatically spin up and then it needs
a lot of setup done on it or in someone
needs like the verdict and SSH into run
like a ton of command to check a lot of
different output install things we also
didn't want to create these really sort
of bolting custom ami if we wanted to be
as possible just kind of like an
offsetting so go obviously very nice for
this fits the binaries are statically
linked drop it in and go we actually
don't need any dependencies before the
actual program the actual agent program
we also something that was a little bit
this had to be a huge bonus business
misko compiles so quickly
the the code changes a lot and has
actually rebuilt dynamically by the
program text that its own code has
changed so we didn't that's part of the
program flow we didn't want that to sort
of block and stall and take a long time
I was compiling before it actually run
because it's really nervous before a
compile stage or if our ten years of
waiting on the test results was really
no reason to delay those tests because
we're compiling our own program and
taking all that yeah so this is is
another situation where we're sort of
decided okay we'd like to use go or we
picked it up we learn to go
I learned it very fast it's pretty as I
mentioned a very sort of simple language
easy learn and there's another thing
where we just had
the whole thing's actually ridden go and
it's going to be a pretty big project
right now it's really not difficult to
maintain it's been pretty sort of simple
to keep each other in the structure I
was a little bit of maintenance of
course but when I got there I don't know
how to organize a go project but it's we
think it became pretty clear and it's
sort of definitely something that I
would go for again if we were going back
in it a whole decision thank you ok so
that's actually it for the first part of
the talk before I mention more to tell
us about the backup service but thanks
are there need that was there's a lot
are there any questions or anything with
it within there
thank you to find the name master
that means Mandela's machine you have
like a walk machine master machine could
it be fine what's the master master it
was almost a mass machine you're
referring to the 90 or the continuous
build system or the master slave yeah
yeah when Matt's machine goes with it
then that's much so that's just a single
um it's like a pretty cool eet
coincidence that we have up that has
basically it runs all of the programs
that are central to a continuous
integration system working there runs
the all of the sort of the scheduled the
scheduler for the different worker
machines has me it has all of sort of
everything that interfaces with the
actual database that we use it's backing
storage it pulls rdy server and it holds
the API server that all the worker
machines report back to will lock their
progress since that basically at some
point at a certain point we needed a
sort of central brain of the whole
system and it's a bunch of different
processes but they all kind of live
together
I thought this means that 10 genius
machine but this is much not currently
recording to machine here right Meadows
oh it's the kind side
that's a separation so it's 1 unless you
look at if you we have it here yeah
wasn't easy to but we it's interesting
that if you were running your own
implemented open-source that you would
be running sort of dominated in front of
your own deployment of it you would be
installing these processes onto machine
that you were running on so you would be
installing the brain of your system on a
machine that you wanted but for our
purposes we keep it as a single machine
that we gotta be teacher so so like if
you if you were gonna it what's the
photos open source if you were gonna
pull it down and start testing your
system you wouldn't be using the same
master machine that we're using you
would have to set up your own be a big
focus on here
your neck support did will they support
testing at CVS it there's no reason to
win it there's no reason it shouldn't we
just since we get the first module that
we very important is for it but this
does nothing in the design that it
shouldn't be able to support system
yeah
your experience with it so far what are
the
they're artists or it's very insert it
can be sometimes frustrating to work
with is very needed so if you're sort of
debugging something I first of all
Google accounts unused in courses and
compiler unused variables or a compiler
and that I mean if you're just debugging
something like that print lines to make
sure it's working
that can get pretty annoying but sort of
like a live with it and this is also
basic mitigating that there's a lot of
stories of trying to ignore things but
that at first is slightly frustrating
also it's because it's like a very
flexible language and since it doesn't
have like a rigid class structure that
you always use for everything it's when
you're like first sort of looking at how
a project can be set up it's not exactly
intuitive boys and she like I'll get one
quest does this and talks request it
does this dependence of these small
subclasses stay sort of be to mess
around with it a little bit to figure to
get the actual structure right
part of that is why it's very flexible
toys
sorry for this we have a iraq you know
it's about everything I gave it every
night it would be hot but it become a
new stock today we do it like we right
now we have it every like X min so we do
it really got a tiny threshold it's like
if it's been a certain every commit if
it's in a certain time since the last
one that we built and then if one gets
gift in there that we really want to go
really like a button India kicks it off
manually one more should I progressed on
tobacco
so this is a little different this is a
sort of overview or power of how our new
backup service works and just a little
bit about sort of how how it's used how
it works what the ideas behind it are so
first of all what is longer than a
management service so it's sort of MMS
was originally Monaco monitor and
service and are sort of expanding it to
be more of a suite of tools for working
with quantities the monitoring is has
been around a long time it's very very
mature and it's basically as an agent
that you install that sits on your
machine talks to your longer piece and
then it sends the stats back to us so if
you want to go online to the MMS
attention calm and you can look at a lot
of sort of things that might help me
debug what your slow or why something
might have crashed god forbid or sort of
just help you basically tune your tune
your entire clusters or things like
[ __ ] that's counters page page fault
index case a lot of other things that
you might want to see so that's that's
entirely free and we're sort of
expanding the more it to be a suite of
tools so the next one that were throwing
out basically recently
is posted backgrounds so service
finishing where we actually store data
for you that's backing up your data
hours the overview I sort of went over
on the other on the other talk but it
all just mention quickly bit it's a
single agents inside their machines to
tafseer MongoDB sends the data back to
us we started a patriotic snapshots and
we store the log and injuries that
you're sending back to us they're not
the same thing
so the way that to the point in time
that the that's another's life but I'll
cover it now so so basically we we did
initially think we get all the data we
take a permanent snapshot of it then we
start getting the out logs so every six
hours we take like a frozen snapshot of
the data I explore that in like a clock
storage and then we store 48 hours worth
of aqua so basically you can do a point
in time restore from any time in the
last 48 hours because what we do is say
you want to do one for two o'clock 2:00
p.m. and the last we was snapshot of 12
we don't have a snapshot it to all we
have to do because within the last 48
hours we still have those off logs we
just take the snapshot from noon and we
apply the off logs that happen between
that and 2:00 p.m. and
a point in time Virginia so there's sort
of a part of the same whole system
for sharted clusters we pause the
balancer every six hours to take a
snapshot the balancers the process that
ensures that basically chunks within
different shards are certain balance
pretty well that you're not going to
have a ton of trying to see like what a
shard is getting off more rights than
the other and it ends up having a lot
more data on it the balancer will split
that data into chunks that move those
chunks around to other shards to ensure
that sort of all the shards have a
similar amount of data so we in order to
take a sort of consistent snapshot of a
chart and cluster we have to turn that
process off because otherwise we might
have done if we take a snap did we like
to take a snap that I did at one point
and that take a snapshot of somewhere of
another shard later there could be data
loss potentially the junk isn't looking
so what we do is we ensure that no auth
token and all of the Yaak logs for every
representative shard as well as for the
[ __ ] s routers which are the just the
process that you've actually connected
from the application that grouts queries
to the appropriative shard based on what
data is there
we you know created NOAA across those
across the [ __ ] s and across the config
servers which are just the three [ __ ]
DS that contain metadata for the cluster
that Congress uses to score bookkeeping
about what shards are or what chunks of
data are on which charts so then once we
have that we have sort of a point in
time that we
yeah we are fighting off water to our
own replica sets until that point and
then we have a snapshot of your data at
that point that we our story were
assured that there's no data loss is no
dead motion at the time that were taking
the snapshot and we can be certain that
we're not getting you faulty data back
over to be inconsistent data when you
restore
so I mentioned point in time basically
to restore a tiny point in time they can
last 48 hours because that's where we
have a lot of snow as both any snapshot
that we've taken from before that for
restoration either pulls from a custom
URL that we can give you or you can
request that we push it we have Cydia
directly to your machines and this gives
you tar.gz data files so you can
actually just open those drop-in
tomography and start it and you should
be fully restored and fully working and
a lot of people actually use this
because so we give unlimited free
restores because another sort of nice
benefit from it is that if you want to
create a few a parchment or create a
play a dev environment without with all
the same data as your production system
without backing up the production system
while you're getting into that you can
just pull up you can just restore from
us have that data set up a great
environment using it for a dev
environment and and you'll be good you
have a great production system at all
this is a confident slide that basically
does since the backup system was created
by the same people that created MongoDB
we know what we're doing we do is
created by people with a lot of
experience using exactly how I'm going
to be so they sort of knew where the
pitfalls work and how to ensure
consistency how to ensure that there
aren't any issues with using it and then
everything sticks around and is
perfectly exactly what you expect it to
be so it really probably the attendant
need to be writing any sort of custom
background scripts that can operate
quick so quickly on how to get started
with mms this is for MS as a whole which
is monitoring in the backups so if you
have an account at MMS dr. tempo calm
you can install the monitoring agent on
your deployment and both open account
with MMS and the monitoring agent itself
are feeling free and we highly recommend
that anyone using well maybe uses these
they're very quick it's very quick to
set up and if something does go wrong or
you start to see little queries or you
want to sort of tune the performance of
your system you can look at every best
potential calm no need you're going to
sort of progressed with your databases
and see exactly what's happening and in
your cluster for the backups you could
ended up home and I said
backups you install it backup agent
Victo program I was talking about
earlier earlier you pointed to your mom
Cody
yeah and start off the sink and you're
good you have back